Riley I want to ask you why you chose to
spoke speak out because my my issue with
this oftentimes and I know a lot of
people have the same issue is they say
if this is really affecting women then
women need to be the ones speaking out
on this issue and there are so many who
are silent why did you make the decision
to speak out and why do you think a lot
of women in your position choose not to
speak out
um I think people don't speak out um
because they're scared they're told
they'll be canceled they have to face
the woke mob but speaking from my
experience I have had tenfold support in
terms or in comparison to anything
negative I the only negative comments
that I've received which has been very
few
um is either you're transphobic which is
not true you're bad at swimming why
didn't you just swim faster
um I'm not bad at swimming or you're
ugly which I also don't think is true
and so those are ridiculous um it rolls
off my back and I I wish more people
would realize that there are so many
more people in this country who can
recognize that this is wrong and
recognize that this is unfair
um but it's been made evident that that
or the minority here is
um loud about it and they're wanting you
to believe there are more
people agreeing with them than there
really are
um I mean females make up 50 let's say
of the world's population
um the transgender Community I don't
know exact statistics but what half a
percent so we're really catering
everything that you know the past 50
years Title IX has aimed to
um you know what it's aimed to improve
and what it was intended or created to
protect
um we're catering that to maybe half a
percent of the population
I mean it's utterly ridiculous to say
that it's transphobic to Simply
acknowledge biological differences
between men and women and to Simply
acknowledge that if you have biological
men infiltrating women's sports for
biological women there's going to be an
injustice a grave Injustice and it's
happening you see it so it's it's you
know that is a very weak talking point
and I say this all the time these people
who who don't know how to really debate
the issue or aren't on the side of facts
they just vomit out these words
transphobic bigoted racist I mean
whatever word they can come up with
you're ugly I mean utterly ridiculous
stuff often oftentimes personal attacks
because they are not on the side of the
facts and not on the side of reality and
this is a pattern that we unfortunately
see unfolding in many different Arenas
not just this one but also the political
Arena and whatnot I want to just ask you
before we go over to Natalia you've been
very lucky
um and then we're going to come back for
a few more questions you've been very
lucky lucky to have the support of your
University do you hear from any students
who see you out there front and center
you've been on some very big no name
shows talking about this do you hear
from them saying they don't necessarily
have the support they are scared asking
advice what to do wanting to speak out
but being concerned have you had those
conversations behind the scenes
oh yeah
um I've realized that my situation is an
anomaly that's why in the beginning of
this interview I mentioned how grateful
I am for the University of Kentucky for
you know protecting me and encouraging
me to speak my heart
um because there are so many girls
across the NCAA who have said to me you
know my coaches won't let me say
anything my athletic director won't let
me speak out about this they want me to
go to Media training I actually had tons
of Leah's teammates reach out to me and
say how can we speak out about this what
can we do without having our athletic
careers threatened and things like that
and so it is definitely like they are
trying to instill fear among their
athletes and it's it's wrong it's a at
this point this is becoming a
you know that we're
our free freedom of speech is being
infringed upon so it's not just at this
point our Athletics there's so much more
that's going into this now and so
um I'm just really grateful that I
haven't had to deal with that I don't
know if it would have changed much
um since I am someone who has always
been brought up to speak my mind
um to never waver from your beliefs and
so but I'm extremely grateful that I
have had that support because it makes a
difference yeah let me just remind the
women out there any any female athletes
who are listening to this there is power
in numbers always so it may be
terrifying for you to speak out on your
own it becomes much less terrifying when
there are many people involved and I say
this you know
um audience knows I say this about every
issue that even you know during covet
times I was advocating for businesses to
speak up and saying you have to kind of
speak up together it can't just be one
business it has to be businesses at
large so if you're out there and you're
worried about speaking up the answer may
be to solidify a group of women who are
valuable who have trained extensively
and speak out together because that
always makes a bigger mark and it
becomes much harder to penalize people
when they're standing firm together on
an issue if you like the short clip you
can catch another one here or you can
catch the full episode right here
[Music]